jean baptiste c'est un adolescent qui
est prêt à tout justement pour accéder à
son rêve devenir footballeur
professionnel fédéral il arrive avec ce
complexe devenir de la campagne
d'arriver dans un milieu urbain où on
est dans quelque chose dont ils
échangent un peu plus violents et
agressifs que ce que les personnages à
l'habitude a pris un coup quoi touch pro
maire d'écuires
il a envie de montrer aux autres ce
qu'il sait faire il a envie surtout de
montrer au coach et à véd'a ce qui peut
faire tu remplaces eux mêmes ce que tu
veux te seuil de capitaux vers les
jeunes il veut il veut rentrer en ligue
il est prêt à tout
ton portrait je les fais pour toi je
pense que ce qui rapproche lille à ib
c'est justement leur différence c'est
que pour gilbert moment ça c'est un
échappatoire
je vais pas qu'on fasse on discutait
il a c'est une jeune adolescente en fait
qui est fan de street art jeu tomb
raider gamme au vote cette fille parce
que tu fais là je les connais mes
dessins rien on n'est pas dans le même
monde déjà on est vraiment à l'opposé
c'est une nana qui est plutôt assez en
marge
contrairement à tous les autres
personnages du film elle est dans sa
bulle elle est un peu dans son monde et
c'est ça qui est très intéressant en
contraste avec justement toute cette
équipe de foot et c'est cet univers là